American people were with are with you
every step of the way it's real those of
you who've been to America know that
there is a
there is a large population
that is invested in what happens here
that cares a great deal about what
happens here
supporting the people of Northern
Ireland protecting the peace preserving
the Belfast Good Friday agreement is a
priority
for Democrats and Republicans alike in
the United States and that is unusual
today because we've been very divided on
our parties
this is something that brings Washington
together
it brings America together I spoke about
this with Northern Ireland's political
leaders as well the t-shirt and I say
Patrick's Day celebration at the White
House
it's been a key Focus for me throughout
my career
I remember working as a senator to see
how the United States could support and
encourage bit by bit any move toward
peace I got elected in 1972 as a 29 year
old kid to the United States Senate
and it was just the start of it I mean
it seemed like it was a a goal that was
so far away
I remember coming here as I said in 91
seeing the city divided and barricaded
then in 94 when the ceasefire was
declared it was like a sea change
tide of violence began to recede hope
rolling in in 1998 overwhelming Joy
it's hard to communicate just How Deeply
invested your success in your success
the people across the United States are
and those who have been there know it
you know it I'm not making this up this
is real this is it's almost people can
taste it